If I'm supposed to be off dairy for my cancer, can I still eat some butter?
Probably one of the most common questions we get.
So, understand, when we test you, we're testing you for what we believe is a food driver to your
cancer. So, if dairy comes up as a food driver to your cancer, you want to not eat dairy.
But it's within balance. We're not talking about you having dairy antibodies to dairy
proteins to k-seen. That's what we're talking about. We're not talking about a food sensitivity
that if you eat it, you're going to have this horrible reaction and you get sick.
So, what are we talking about if you eat a little butter that your cancer is going
to take off and grow? Though, when it tests as a driver for your cancer, you want to cut
out like 95% of that if possible. So, okay, where would I be getting more growth factors
from a dairy product by eating, putting a little butter on my toast or whatever I'm eating
or by eating a bowl of ice cream? Well, pretty simple answer to that.
So when you're off of a food because it's a driver to the cancer, it's not, it's a occult.
This is a religion. Does it mean that dairy butter is probably a much better choice than
the butter substitutes out there? But, you know, cheese and how about the cheese substitutes?
Well, I don't know. There's a lot of credit in cheese too even if you didn't have dairy as
an issue. But it's so stayed off of something you're trying to eliminate 90 to 95% of that
thing in your diet to decrease a feed the fuel source for the cancer so things slow down.
So to answer the question, yeah, you could still eat some butter. Should you eat it like
it's going out of style? Probably not. But it's better than probably better than the butter
substitutes. It's all about balance. So not trying to make this an idol in your life with
your diet or anything you're doing, you're trying to, you know, take a reasonable approach
to help your body fight this.